I'd consider myself quite a good reader
so and even I found it quite hard myself
so I was panicking I was like I'm not
going to be able to finish so I was
sitting there like
I'm not gonna be able to pass or I'm not
going to get the grade I expected some
questions I did leave and when I went
back I had to skim read and I couldn't
find them they're talking about their
SATs reading test I try not to get too
stressed but inside I was like
screaming it was much more difficult
than pupils or teachers had prepared for
and left some children in tears some of
them were
um quite distraught really because it
just wasn't what they were expecting I
think it was one of the trickiest ones
that I've ever seen in my time here we
can't show the test as some pupils could
still be sitting it this week but we've
been told that children had to read
3443 words of text and questions one of
the longest SATs reading tests ever it
means a child reading at the minimum
speed for that age would spend 38
minutes and 14 seconds reading out of
the hour allocated so they'd have just
34 seconds to answer each question
the content of the test has also been
criticized it included cultural
references and expressions that would
have made it difficult for some children
to understand and the way some questions
were worded left even teachers wondering
what it was getting at
many parents are unhappy some of the
girls are crying and I believe the
teacher said it was harder than previous
years it's quite harsh for them really
to have that extra pressure put on them
after hundreds of complaints the schools
Minister has agreed to look into it the
stanzan testing agency was conduct the
SAS test they test these tests over many
years they're testing with children and
they are assured that it was the the
right test for the children this year
challenging of course because it has to
test a whole range of abilities but I'll
certainly be looking at the test as I do
every year when the tests are available
to the public the head teacher of this
school near Stafford wants the
government to go further so what I'd
like to say is some adjustment in the
marking some flexibility in their
approach to looking at the questions and
potentially lowering the pass marks SATs
matter to schools it's how they're
ranked in league tables it'll be an
anxious wait until July when they get
the results Becky Johnson Sky News
Staffordshire